Tapia's jeremy clarkson returning home
to waiting photographers after his
suspension by the BBC for what they have
called africa but now the allegations
against him have taken a new direction
people in the hotel bar where it
happened say he used foul language and
told a colleague he have him fired in a
row over food the ward family from Leeds
told me they were excited to be on
holiday last Wednesday at the same
Yorkshire Dales hotel as the top gear
team that is until the presenters
arrived at half past 9:00 at night
Jeremy Clarkson come through and said
any chance of a selfie Jeremy and he
says no not wet dare that I bought today
so I'm more less sat down with my tail
between my legs within minutes they say
Clarkson directed a torrent of
four-letter abuse at a colleague he
hadn't done his job properly and it was
ridiculous that there was nothing to eat
and that he would obviously there's lots
of expletives in between all this and
that he it would it would be losing his
job he would see to it that it would
lose his job just the shock of how comes
I'm so rude you know the fact Navin is
photographing we understood that
completely and the must get fed up with
that but it was just the swearing and
the length of time and this poor guy
that it were ripping into
Top Gear is the BBC's biggest global
brand worth more than 50 million pounds
a year but we've Clarkson suspended the
next three episodes have been scrapped
more than three-quarters of a million
people have signed a petition for him to
keep his job the only big top gear fan
among the ward family thinks he should
his brush we know we know what he's like
he's willing to do but before I think
he'll be in trouble again but I don't
think he'll lose his job at BBC I think
you'll continue to little that job
because without glasses did not tell me
I don't think among the holiday snaps
the wards took last week of the Top Gear
cars and the snow is one last picture
the patio the morning after the Rauh at
an empty hotel a distant figure with his
back to the camera
Jeremy Clarkson alone and facing an
uncertain future jared sub Sky News
Leeds